the update function for the world object
is called step and its inputs are a
little bit tricky so let's take a look
at them the first parameter here
represents the frame rate frequency that
our physics engine uses to track through
its calculations think of this value is
the amount that we want the physics
engine to move the physics world forward
each computational frame and of course
we want this value to match what the
visual world update loop is doing to
otherwise things might feel off now for
our purposes we make the assumption that
the game is running at a solid 60 frames
a second thus we expect the update loop
to be called 60 times a second giving us
a time slice value of 1 over 60 next we
pass two values to the step function
which represent the number of iterations
that the physics engine should spend
solving collisions and velocities to
ensure proper placement now without
going into too much detail solving for
collisions in an environment while also
ensuring that objects aren't
interpenetrating is actually a pretty
cumbersome process and can't really be
solved in a single pass
for example consider if two objects are
penetrating and fixing the penetration
causes a penetration collision with a
new object and of course in turn fixing
that one may cause yet another collision
and so on and so on
as such the physics engine will do
passes over the physics object and solve
the items iteratively
the number we pass in here represents
how many passes box2d should do before
moving on ie the higher the numbers are
the more precise the collision data
since we're iterating to find a solution
the lower the number the less precise
the collision information but the more
performant it is because we're not
spending extra cycles